star trek strange new world looks
awesome
but is it just going to be another
effing pile of star trek modern crap
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
the new adverts have been coming out
for strange new worlds and i got to
admit
on the surface they look really cool
i love the uh the way the starship
enterprise is flying in that big arc in
circle with the other vessel firing upon
it it makes the enterprise look kind of
sleek and
fast and maneuverable which you know
maybe in the past we haven't actually
seen that from federation starships a
great deal
let's show them what you got
it looks kind of cool some of the sets
and some of the adventures are going to
get up to look kind of cool
kurtzman has promised that this series
will not be
anything like discovery that we are
going to maybe have double episodes and
repeat episodes and and arcing stories
but we're also going to get back to an
episodic style a new starship a new bad
guy a new something every single week
they are going to be genuinely going out
there and exploring strange new worlds
and we're going to get to see a lot of
star trek that we've never never seen
before and a star trek style of show
that we haven't seen for a very long
time
so there's a lot for us to be excited
about we've already met a couple of the
characters like number one and spock and
pike and we liked them the best thing
about series 2 discovery was pike
but what the hell have they done to that
man's hair
hi
i love this job
it it every time i see the adverts all i
can see is a massive grey quiff
and i can't i can't i can't not see it
it's it's all i see he's talking and i'm
not really sure what's going on
also it seems that they've changed the
character slightly
now it does seem from the advert that
something has happened to pike we see
him on earth big beard riding his horse
in the snow a shuttle comes down
something has happened to him
and that's going to change in the way he
then behaves later but they do seem to
change the character they seem to have
made him a little goofier than he was in
discovery it seems to be that they've
actually brought maybe more of mounts
the actual actor's character through
into this new version of pike and he is
kind of a goofy guy i've seen him in
lots of interviews and things he's a
very funny guy
they maybe sort of tried to bring a bit
more of that through and have injected a
little bit of humor into the star trek
series which would actually be quite
nice because it is something that maybe
is lacking from most star trek
but it is a change
and i worry that maybe
he won't be as likeable as he was before
i hope they're not trying too hard with
the new pike
you want to seek out new life
[Music]
go where the aliens are your presence is
blasphemy let's talk about this find
some conflict
i think that went well we do have things
like christina chong's character la ann
nooni and singh
now that is obviously going to be a
relative of khan
and that is an exciting storyline i i
really like that idea it is postcard
obviously because khan at the moment
would be on the botany bay floating in
the middle of nowhere fast asleep it
could be his like great great
granddaughter we're not 100 certainly
aware star trek strangely worlds is
going to sit in the timeline so we'll
have to
i'm sure once season one gets kicks off
we'll know a bit more about that
but that has a really interesting
opportunity and i hope they actually do
something with that i hope it's not just
basically a name and okay she's going to
be an augment of some sort
but let's hope they actually do
something interesting it gives us a bit
more of an insight into basically one of
star trek's best villains
the biggest risk i see and the biggest
danger with strange new worlds
is canon now if you are a regular
sidetracker you'll know i'm not a big
fan of prequels i think prequels are a
massive risk i think prequels more often
than not destroy the tv show and take a
massive steaming pile of crap on cannon
in this case it's a massive risk because
they're actually messing potentially
with the original series
and a run-up to the most beloved of all
star treks the original series
i don't know why they keep having to
remake the original series
i don't know why we're going to be now
onto our third kirk but we'll get on to
that in a second and
even though i can completely understand
the interest in explaining the pike
character more we got to love him i
completely understand why he was in
discovery
i don't quite understand why they're
going to now have a series running up to
kirk taking over
so we've only got about a five year
period between what we know happened in
discovery and then when we know kirk
took over the enterprise and then we
know what happened to pike through the
episodes imaginary from the original
series
so
there's not a lot of space there for
them to fill the seven series if this
show is popular generally star trek
series aim for seven so
are we going to actually see the early
days of kirk now we know that in series
two we're going to see kirk
some of the photos look like he sat on
the bridge of the enterprise now there's
nothing actually in canon to say kirk
didn't meet pike earlier so they could
have met but we know from the menagerie
episodes really that spock felt like he
had a loyalty to pike he felt like he
owed pike
kirk doesn't show that kirk acts like he
barely knows him
so
it would suggest
that pike and kirk in this universe
forgetting the jj abrams kelvin timeline
where they did know each other really
well
don't really know each other
particularly
but in star trek looking at what jj
abrams did and thinking that's a
relationship we actually want to grow
let's have that let's have that you know
like father figure in pike and a young
kirk sort of thing let's create a
storyline that in the original series
didn't exist so basically are they going
to crackle over cannon
probably kurtzman's done it before and
i'm sure he'll actually do it again look
at basically everything he does in
discovery does what he likes and he
doesn't really worry about original star
trek or are we going to get an insight
into an exciting period of time those
first few years before the original
series kicked off
i have no trust in kurtzman
i
didn't like supercard series one i i
hated the end and i thought generally
the series was massive like that i think
picard series 2 has started very well i
am not a huge fan of discovery i think
it does crackle over canon it barely
makes sense at times and there's no
character to it at all
they do seem to be trying something
different with strange new worlds for
what they're obviously going to try to
make this far more character driven than
they have with discovery
these people
this crew
i believe we can do anything
the fact that they've released these
trailers where they do these little
trailers they've released a pike trailer
and a number one trailer and a spock
trailer a little trail is about all the
different characters showing us little
bits of what is going on with them
through these series
that show that tells me that they're
trying to be far more character-driven
they're still going to be obviously a
lot of story going on but they're going
to try to do something different
perhaps we should kiss that seems
logical
now i want a character-driven show the
next generation was amazing because of
the characters the original series was
amazing because of the characters
characters they keep recasting and
remaking
so a new series that is far more
character-driven than the incredibly
forgettable characters of discovery
would be a breath of fresh air and as i
say the trailer
makes this series look incredible it is
stunningly beautiful but discovery was
stunningly beautiful and i still don't
like it
this is your captain
our mission
to chart the stars
so let's see what they do i'm hoping
that prank gets a haircut i'm hoping
that the characters are as interesting
as they look and i'm really hoping they
do something with khan's great
granddaughter but let's see how the
cookie crumbles because we're not going
to know really until we get to mid
season in the first season of what we're
going to expect and then to be honest i
am dreading season two because
i have a horrible feeling i know what
they're going to do with kirk and if
they do i'm not watching it
so
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification really helps us out and get
into the comments tell me what you think
about strange new worlds are you as
excited about it as i am but at the same
time as weary of it as i am
please get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think
also if you'd like to become a fully
fledged side tracker you can hit the
join button and support the channel
please as always stay safe i'll see you
really soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you